[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
niedrige Sirin Ihnen allen einen schönen
guten Abend an diesem Pfingstsonntag
alle sportliche hat später Norbert König
ja gibt noch was an diesem Sonntag guten
Abend wir blicken auf die Themen
Stichwahl in der Türkei nach aktuellem
Stand wird es für Präsident Erdogan wohl
knapper als gedacht
feiern und feuern während beim FC Bayern
Männer und Frauen ihre Meisterschaften
gemeinsam bejubeln ist die Trennung von
Oliver Kahn wohl eher unschön abgelaufen
es wäre eine Sensation gestern das
mitreißende WM Halbfinale jetzt könnten
die deutschen Eishockeyspieler im
Endspiel Geschichte schreiben
es ist der Abend der Entscheidung in der
Türkei Amtsinhaber Erdogan hat die
Stichwahl gegen seinen Herausforderer
Rollo offenbar knapp gewonnen sollte es
dabei bleiben bedeutet dies dass all
jene die sich einen Kurswechsel hin zu
einer liberaleeren Türkei gewünscht
haben enttäuscht werden über den Ausgang
der ersten Stichwahl der türkischen
Geschichte berichtet jetzt Anna Feist
noch will nicht so recht Feierstimmung
aufkommen vor der AKP Zentrale in
Istanbul die ersten Zahlen zeigen
nämlich ein knapperes Rennen als
erwartet knapp über 50% für Erdogan
knapp unter 50% für grillits der Rollo
ja die Aufregung ist groß wir warten
noch sie öffnen gerade die Uhren wir
hatten eigentlich ein besseres Ergebnis
erwartet mit Gottes Hilfe Siegen wir und
die ganze Welt wird unsere Macht zu
spüren bekommen Stunden zuvor war der
Optimismus riesig schon am Vormittag
gibt sich Präsident Erdogan im
feiertagsmodus verteilt wie es sonst nur
an Feiertagen üblich ist Lira Scheine
vor dem Wahllokal in Istanbul am Abend
soll dann Erdogans Wahlparty anders als
sonst nicht vor der AKP zentrale sondern
direkt vor dem Präsidialamt in Ankara
steigen die Vorbereitungen laufen sein
gegen Kandidat College wie auch in der
ersten Runde umringt von
Personenschützern mutmaßlich mit Schuss
sicherer Weste an der Wahlurne in Ankara
zuversichtlich ist sie nicht die
Opposition selbst dieser Abgeordnete
dessen Partei die Opposition unterstützt
gibt sich zurückhaltend
sicherlich Hoffnung gibt es immer aber
es ist unbestreitbar dass wir
pessimistisch sind was das Ergebnis
angeht
diese Wahl sei ein Referendum über die
Zukunft der Türkei sagt er noch
insbesondere für die jungen Leute
ich werde gehen wenn Erdogan gewinnt
verlasse ich das Land
doch noch sind nicht alle Stimmen
ausgezählt noch ist das Rennen nicht
vorbei
wir gehen in die türkische Hauptstadt
nach Ankara zu Jörg Brase Jörg was sind
denn jetzt die aktuellsten Zahlen
also es gibt zwei Agenturen die den
jeweils politischen Lagern nahe stehen
und deren Zahlen deren sich immer weiter
an die Pegeln sich im Moment ein bei
einem Vorsprung für Präsident Erdogan
von ungefähr drei bis vier Prozent ein
stabiler Vorsprung mit dem der
amtszenhaber offensichtlich gerechnet
hat denn zum ersten Mal hat er seine
Unterstützer nicht vor die
Parteizentrale in Agrar sondern hier vor
den
Präsidentenpalast eingeladen hier finden
sich immer mehr Leute ein die sich auf
die Siegesfeier heute Abend vorbereiten
erdogan hat den Istanbul gewählt er wird
noch im Laufe des Abends hier erwartet
und wird dann zu seinen Anhängern
sprechen wenn sich da jetzt nichts
ändert was bedeutet das für die Türkei
also die Opposition befürchtet natürlich
dass es jetzt ein knoch-auto retäreren
Kurs geben wird wir haben es im Stück
gesehen vor allem Oppositionelle Kurden
bereiten sich darauf vor das Land zu
verlassen oder haben das bereits getan
wahrscheinlich werden auch viele
Jugendliche sich überlegen ihr Glück im
Ausland zu suchen denn es wird damit
gerechnet dass auch die Finanzmärkte auf
dieses Wahlergebnis reagieren dass der
Kurs der türkischen Lira noch weiter
fallen könnte danke für diese Live
Informationen aus Angerer Jörg Brase
im
US-Schuldenstreit haben sich
US-Präsident beiden und die Republikaner
grundsätzlich geeinigt und wohl einen
Zahlungsausfall der größten
Volkswirtschaft der Welt abgewendet im
Kern geht es um eine Anhebung der
Schulden Obergrenze in den kommenden
zwei Jahren im Gegenzug wird bei den
Staatsausgaben gekürzt der Kongress muss
den Kompromiss noch absegnen
die Ukraine meldet die massivsten
Drohnenangriffe seit Beginn des
russischen Angriffskrieges mindestens
ein Mensch wurde getötet in Kiew wurden
nach Angaben des Militärkommandos mehr
als 40 Drohnen abgeschossen Trümmerteile
beschädigten Häuser in der besonders
umkämpften Stadt bachmut zeigen diese
Aufnahmen der russischen
Nachrichtenagentur Taste das Ausmaß der
Zerstörung Moskau behauptet macht Mut
sei vollständig erobert die Ukraine
widerspricht
unionsfraktionsvize Spahn stellt die von
der großen Koalition eingeführte Rente
mit 63 in Frage ein Grund für seinen
Vorstoß sei der Fachkräftemangel zwei
millionenfachkräfte die früher in Rente
gegangen sein fehlten nun bitterlich so
sparen in der Bild am Sonntag
nach Frankreich knapp zwei Wochen lang
blickte die Filmwelt nach kann gestern
Abend dann die Preisverleihung beim wohl
bedeutendsten Filmfestival die Goldene
Palme für den besten Film ging an die
französische Regisseurin Justine Trier
für ihren Film Anatomie dünnschild mit
der deutschen Schauspielerin Sandra
Höller in der Hauptrolle als bester
männlicher Darsteller wurde der Japaner
KODi jakuschow ausgezeichnet für seine
Rolle in Wim Wenders Film perfekt
ganz groß gefeiert wird auch gerade in
München am Ende eines turbulenten
fußball-wochenendes kann sich der FC
Bayern gleich über zwei Titel freuen die
Frauen und die Männermannschaft stehen
gemeinsam auf dem Rathaus Balkon und
feiern mit tausenden Fans ihre
Meisterschaften denn nach den Männern
gestern haben die Frauen heute
nachgezogen und sich am Nachmittag
ebenso die Schale gesichert mit einem
Kantersieg von 11 zu 1 gegen Potsdam
ja und auf dem Münchner Marienplatz ist
Jutta sonnewald für uns Titel jeweils
für die Männer und Frauen des FC Bayern
Jutta was sagen die Münchner zum double
[Musik]
Marienplatz sind völlig außer Rand und
Band tausende haben schon seit den
ganzen Nachmittag hier gewartet um
gemeinsam mit diesen beiden Mannschaften
doppelt diese Doppelmeisterschaft zu
feiern seit etwa einer halben Stunde
sind die beiden Mannschaften auf dem
Balkon des Rathauses alle in Tracht
singen jubeln und feiern hier mit den
Menschen und ich glaube es sind ein so
besonderer Tag ja auch weiter gefeiert
dieses Spektakel hier am Marienplatz
vorbei ist vielen Dank nach München
also Freude über die Meisterschaften
aber Norbert der FC Bayern der trägt ja
nicht umsonst diesen spitznam FC
Hollywood Stichwort Oliver Kahn Rauswurf
ja da bleiben noch einige Fragen offen
und das wird sicherlich alle noch eine
ganze Weile beschäftigen als die Spieler
den Meistertitel Nummer 33 feiert und da
war die de mission von Hassan salamitic
und Oliver Kahn schon längst
beschlossene Sache sportlich Ende gut
aber beim FCB längst nicht alles gut
in der 89 Minute kommt jamalmusialas
magischer Moment sein 2:1 gegen Köln
lässt die Bayern ausflippen Meister
Jubel wurde er emotionalste Titel seit
Jahren doch gestern und heute
überstrahlt der doppelrauswurf von
Hassan Salihamidzic und Oliver Kahn die
Party wieso durfte can nicht ins Stadion
Bayern Boss Herbert Heiner erklärt das
mit dem Ablauf des entlassungsgesprächs
das ist leider nicht so gut gelaufen
muss ich sagen das war sehr emotional
und wir konnten uns am Ende des Tages
mit Oliver nicht einigen dass er die
Beendigung einvernehmlich hinkriegen
kann selbst kontert bereits vor der
Pressekonferenz reagiert auf
Medienberichte die Behauptung dass ich
ausgerastet bin als ich über die
Abberufung informiert wurde stimmt
definitiv nicht kannst Nachfolger als
Vorstands Boss wird der bisherige
Finanzvorstand Jan Christiansen
Karl-Heinz Rummenigge soll zurückkehren
in den Aufsichtsrat gemeinsam mit
Trainer Tuchel und einem neuen
Sportvorstand sollen sie den FC Bayern
der Zukunft bauen
Franziska Müllers hat für uns die
Pressekonferenz beobachtet ist das ganze
auch ein
Kommunikationsdesigner Franziska
ja also die Journalisten sind aus dieser
Pressekonferenz mit vielen Fragezeichen
im Gesicht rausgegangen der Grund ist
einfach dass die Aussagen nur die
Diskrepanz zwischen den Aussagen von
Herbert Heiner und Oliver kahnvia
Twitter extrem groß ist man kann schon
von dem kommunikationsdesaster sprechen
auch deswegen weil die Spieler
unmittelbar nach dem Titel gewinnen
davon erfahren haben von diesen
Entlassungen was natürlich die
meisterstimmung extrem geschmälert hat
Herbert Heiner hat diesen doch eher
ungünstigen Zeitpunkt damit
gerechtfertigt das hassic sich gerne
persönlich von den Spielern und
insgesamt der Mannschaft verabschieden
wollte aber die Spieler und Trainer
meisten nach dem letzten
Spieltag unmittelbar weg sind also zum
Beispiel im Urlaub also insgesamt
zusammengefasst kann man sagen ja es
gibt gemischte Gefühle und der FC Bayern
geht mit vielen Fragezeichen in eine
neue Ehre sonst Müllers vielen Dank für
diese Eindrücke aus München
der erste FC Heidenheimer zum ersten Mal
den Sprung in die erste Liga geschafft
in der Nachspielzeit brachte der drei zu
zwei Erfolg bei Absteiger Regensburg
sogar noch die zweite Liga Meisterschaft
nach Null zu zwei Rückstand konnten die
Heidenheimer Fans doch noch jubeln zum
Leidwesen der Anhänger des Hamburger SV
dem das 1:0 in Sandhausen letztlich
nicht zum direkten Aufstieg reichte in
der Relegation wartet der VfB Stuttgart
bei den Ruder Europameisterschaften in
Slowenien hat Oliver Zeitler mit Rang
drei die erhoffte Goldmedaille verpasst
bis zur Hälfte des Rennens hatte der
einer Weltmeister noch geführt dann
zogen der Niederländer von Lorup und
Olympiasieger Stefan Osten aus
Griechenland vorbei Bronze für Zeitler
ist die einzige Medaille für die
deutschen Ruderer bei dieser EM
die deutschen Eishockeyspieler wollen
mehr nach ihrem ohnehin schon
historischen Einzug ins Endspiel der
Eishockey Weltmeisterschaft das DEB-Team
ist nach dem Last Minute Erfolg gegen
die USA voller Optimismus nach Tamper
der gereist in wenigen Minuten geht es
gegen die Eishockey groß macht Kanada es
winkt der erste Titel für Deutschland in
der
103-jährigen WM Geschichte
Fußballspielen können sie offensichtlich
auch schaue ich mir auf jeden Fall an
danke schön Norbert wir schauen jetzt
mal gemeinsam auf das Pfingst am Montag
das Wetter und das geht so in der Mitte
und an den Alpen ist es zeitweise
bewölkt sonst scheint trotz
schleuderwolken die Sonne 20 bis 27 im
Norden und Westen 14 bis 20 Grad
unsere einschalte Empfehlung um 21:45
Uhr das heute journal mit Dunja Hayali
dort auch alles Aktuelle zur Türkei Wahl
das war von uns entspannten Sonntagabend
und gerne bis morgen hier geht's jetzt
weiter mit Chuck unter la Benny